This is Milan's 'Porta Ticinese' district.
It's home to many historic buildings.
But some of the streets have drab architecture,
dating from the 1950s.
They were eyesores, still
Giovanna Cornelio wanted to move into the
8th floor of  this building.
She transformed into a luxurious living space.
“Hello, nice to meet you.
Come in my home."
Inside it's anything but dull and dreary.
The open-plan living room is flooded with
light.
Cornelio turned two apartments into one and
now has 280 square meters of floor space.
She's not bothered that the building's exterior
isn't so appealing.
“I choose this house because of the light,
because of the terrace.
I decide to draw this space according to the light during the day.
So, every room has a different view outside and a different proportion with the light.”
Giovanna Cornelio loves '50s-era design.
These eye-catching chairs are upholstered with fabric used to cover old train seats.
And this Jean Prouvé swing-arm lamp is also a design classic from 1950.
The couch dates from the same era.
“You can use it from this side, or you can
sit on the other side and look in this direction,
or have a sort of day bed.”
The architect designed some of the furniture herself, including this oversized couch and....
the shelving unit across from it.
The kitchen is located on the same floor.
Cornelio employed plenty of stainless steel, to make her kitchen durable and functional.
"A simple design, but with strong materials to use every day.”
Across from the kitchen, the family meets
for meals.
The architect has a 13-year-old daughter and enjoys entertaining friends.
“This is our dining space, with this table
from the fifties drawn by Oswald do Bossani.
The chairs are from the same years.”
A narrow staircase, integrated into the shelving unit, leads up to the 9th floor.
This used to be a windowless room that was used as storage space.
Cornelio replaced the concrete walls with
glass, converting the room into a studio.
“It's a very special place to stay during
the weekend, or in the evening to look at
a film or to work, because it is a completely
isolated box.
You can't imagine to be in a town.”
The studio is almost completely encircled
by an 80 square meter U-shaped terrace.
“You can stay here, reading, working, working
with plants – it’s like to be on holidays.”
From the terrace you can get to the tenth
floor, which the architect also designed herself.
She calls it her sun deck.
"When I did the glasshouse I decide to have a roof to use.
It’s a particular view on the town you never have.
You feel completely free and you forget what you have to do.”
Looking out over Milan from this vantage point puts the buildings some considered
eyesores
in a whole new light.